you
okay let's see if I could do a better
job with the white piece is a knuckle
down material hand that line with a six
the Queens gambit declined stuff okay
let's grab some space sometimes it can
be really stupid when you have a space
advantage and let's go with c4 yeah
hopefully not this okay um you know what
I might want to do just take what the
night
what about g3 what about not let's just
get my night out
efore Knight f3 or my two moves you know
what it's gonna do this Queen a5 stuff
just I don't have a good reply to that
it seems ever ever okay
Knight takes I'd rather not play with
that structure with this I wonder if
it's better to just take with the night
I know I'm running into eventually some
tempo gaining move against my queen I'm
gonna give this a try though yeah let's
see what it has oh really
really now hmm Bishop g5 right Bishop e7
I go for that that seems way too
appealing not to do now I'm gonna take
the bishop and a pin and I'm gonna keep
that pin for a little bit just go one
step I have the bishop here but I'm
going to soon be giving that dark square
bishop back all right where does my
bishop belong probably here just so that
there's no annoying pin back up or just
give the bishop right back
oh let's keep the pin
be a little bit of a pest let's get
castled and from here oh boy okay night
here I guess is coming soon and now what
alright let's trade a little bit let's
trade I'm looking for take stakes and
then win here but that's not happening
you know it is happening soon though
there's pawn push Knight here is no good
because if Knight takes my bishops I'm
protected so I'm thinking I should have
gotten rid of the knight while I had the
chance
I guess I'm giving too much like I'm
thinking I could somehow exploit these
weaknesses I mean that's never gonna
happen against a computer but I don't
know yeah this could be very
uncomfortable very soon
yeah very soon yeah he's kind of a dead
piece I don't like my bishop on g3 Queen
here I get hit one night before what do
I do about this do I take take and then
run away with my queen somewhere I'm
gonna try that
I'm sure if it's any good let's just run
over here okay hmm Knight is hit twice
doesn't have a fantastic home kind I
gotta go there wow what an ugly position
this is a really ugly position my rook
is hit and so is my pawn on b2 look at
how easily that collapses man how easily
it collapses yes I knew that was coming
Queen here Queen takes Knight rook d1
guess down upon and how should I take
I'll open a file for my rep yeah I would
like to get in this well I'm I'm
speechless I'm speechless Knight B 1 2 C
3 I guess
yep - chop my night working can I trade
nights and hope for like an opposite
color Bishop ending that might be
something to try for but this is gonna
be difficult to break down b6 will be in
a5 will be in the night I'll go to be
for I'll probably end up with the
getting hit with the fork like night a 4
does nothing b6 how do I even improve
hmm
unfortunately I'm just in a position
where I can't really improve let's let's
get a flight square I guess you know b6
strengthening move it's just gonna be
too much oh now I have to you know
another thing this pawn as soon as this
is locked down with a 5 it doesn't even
need to be locked down I come over here
Bishop C to either get a file or I lose
another pawn now looking good there I
guess I'll just take I don't really have
anything I'm I'm running out of ways to
even think about improving which is
certainly unfortunate hmm yeah I'm ready
to throw in the towel to be honest I
don't have a way to improve and black
has every way to improve dead duck on b3
I'm down upon he's gonna be one I can't
even get my pawns rolling I can't get my
king active just throw my King away
let's try another one okay all right
you're going down this time buddy you
are going down down
and I've played this way too many times
um please play Bishop f3 yes okay it's
my best opportunity to win if I could
get rid of my bad bishop
okay I've played this before I've had
good positions I had good positions
castle push 97 c5 Knight here okay
let's kick this Knight around a little
bit maybe okay enough of that
what about Knight here to here looking
for some trades
I'll give him a kick oh really I've seen
it do this before and I don't think it's
a good choice I wanna get rid of this
Knight he kind of bothers me let's come
back hmm I wonder if we could trade
Queens can we do that please
let's play here first here's one thing
to be aware of if this capture comes
about I want to take like this as
otherwise I give up this square and you
can be sure the Knights gonna sink
itself right in that point I want to
avoid that Queen here to try and induce
this move let's see that was a bad
choice
I just dropped upon oh my goodness that
was awful that was awful alright let's
go here I'm gonna get hammered now I am
gonna get hammered oh my goodness just
like that yeah how awful is that to lose
a pawn in that way
what did I say I was just gonna play two
games let's try another one
I lied three maybe four who knows I
might be on tilt all of a sudden three
maybe I'll keep going until I win a game
then we could maybe set a record for
stream time okay mmm g3 Bishop g2 let's
see you know I'm not feeling very
confident right now I'm you know these
past couple of games I've just uh what's
what's been happening I've been losing
material that's not any fun I'd really
like to play a game where I'm not
dropping upon so that's what I'm
shooting for here I'm not expecting much
of myself can i play a game where I
don't drop upon we're gonna see about
that
okay let's try rook e1 get an e4 okay
chop and I played I played this type of
position before against it and I dropped
upon again I think I played Bishop d2 it
took my knight and then took on here
I'm ready to lose another fun okay let's
go here though yeah
black is clearly already equalized I got
a dead duck over here um all right let's
get here and then here as soon as
possible okay start to feel a little
more comfortable okay what about just
scoot the Queen up just a little bit
just a hair oh really what am I missing
this thing is kind of out of out of play
isn't he huh I'm not afraid of that
should I be
hmm okay let's chop here all right I'm
in a pen rook takes yeah I need to get
out of this probably here centralize the
Queen and I do so with tempo how bad can
that really be I'm staying on this
diagonal oh I'm liking my position will
not be the first time I like a position
and lose though it's the most confident
statement ever all right double rooks
doubled rooks are double trouble I'm not
afraid of that
no way I am simply not afraid of that
I'll just drop back I feel like I'm
better in this position all right let's
just back up maybe I'll gain a tempo at
a different time against the rook get
him working I have to be better here I
have to be better you got nothing
black hmm where do I go from here though
Queen here maybe it would push cuz how
does it defend here Knight back let's
let's fish for umm oh we're gonna go for
a little dance here perpetual attack
against the Queen I think I have a draw
if I wanted
should I go for a draw I it doesn't
makes me a little happy to go for a drop
rock back over I could get a job okay
mmm I really want to try for more though
I'm greedy I'm going to be greedy
I'm better because I have the better
miner piece I have the better rooks I
have something to bite out here game on
let's go uh-huh I got you where I want
you
let's come back over we're gonna still
do a little dance yeah I thought you'd
do that come back over what about bishop
here there now I'm ready to come there's
no ruck at 5:00 but then you have that
move okay though how bad could this
really be how bad can it really be
chop-chop
Queen here more chops I should still be
okay
I really should still be okay
look at that as soon as my bishop left
from defense in this square okay take
hmm
that I was not expecting I thought the
other Brook would take but all right
let's stay here and take with what piece
let's ply here to make sure my seventh
rank is defended that night gonna kill
me mm-hmm he's already starting to look
like a pest let's get my bishop doing
something he's just staring at a rock
that's not a coup all right I know I
know how to draw this position if my
opponents gonna have an isolated pawn in
such a simplified endgame
I really still feel like I should be
going for more though hmm I'll try this
pond takes hopefully yes I have
something to maybe play for centralize
that Queen King position huh look at how
easy it's just too easy isn't it hmm all
right let's go here I guess hmm check I
don't think I have anything I should
probably repeat at this point down on
time - you're gonna have a repetition
and I don't see these puns you know so
be a draw these puns right here they
creep ever so like I can envision a
position where if the Queen's are off
I'll maybe be able to win this guy but
in return this rook will get one of
these and these guys will be very close
to queening mm-hmm I don't think I could
have done anything
okay I guess we'll try to even it out
okay let's let's try fourth one and this
so this will be it for the five - hmm
okay nimzo-indian oh okay I've had some
success with this and usually it likes
to go for that capture damaging my pawn
structure c4 no all right I'll take pawn
takes or Queen takes Queen takes I have
to worry about this check and grab on b7
so I got rid of my bad bishop I'm
cutting I'm in a pin but I'll break it
soon these positions I could win I think
I think I think I could win these
positions Queen here I won't have to
Queen trade yeah Queen trade I could
force the Queen trade your I got you
where I want you right now let's keep
the watch I'm gonna I'm gonna win this
pawn that's my prediction right here
move ten I will one day win this pawn
right now he will track him down so
let's fix him here it's a very
far-fetched statement look at this King
Wow Wow
I don't want to take the Queen because
it takes here but if pushed then I'll
consider taking so what about a four a
five a four to force this capture that
might be a good idea but maybe what's
best first is to get my knight working
yeah it's to making nothing moves so now
what I don't want to do this I give up
too many good squares I want to be
cautious my opponent has the knight so
let's make sure of what exactly let's
make sure they're not going to be able
to get nice homes so this was my idea
hey five I kind of like that I'm really
drawn to that move okay I'll get some
pawn break in I could
push again the Queen must take
let's go for it alrighty pawn takes I
take like this otherwise Knight here
take like this uh-huh really I'm tempted
to do this move now yeah my knight could
be a pain getting to this square doing
this to casual castle artificially there
might be some pin here okay I need to
drop back let's go here watch over this
square there might be some like Knight
here to here stuff now I could do this
he could be an extremely annoying piece
I think I need to get into a position
where I could challenge the rooks on the
e-file and so what that means is I think
at least I should have my pawn around to
watch over this so I could finally
contest the e-file so okay he where is
he going he's watching over this square
can I open up the other side of the
board though help to do something good
with my bishop what's the point I was
ready to say what's the winning plan I'm
not sure there's a winning plan but if I
could um correctly get a certain type of
pawn break like if I could get my knight
here and then maybe play g5 and for
stakes takes losing my voice takes takes
and then I could push through with maybe
an outside pass pawn one thing I have to
be worried about is this putting
pressure on c6 in some lines
it's my base point hmm it seems like a
strictly defensive move excuse me Knight
to d2 I'm not I just baby step it here
for our moment
there's this putting pressure on that
night all the more appealing now I think
I want to keep one rook on the board
maybe not I don't want to take care
although no I could take care if paan
takes I play here and I lock down on e4
make sure that's never gonna be played
so what about I don't want to trade
anymore what about this here and then
something like this I don't want to
declare my bishops intentions just yet
let's do this just yet because again I
want to keep an eye on b4 with this
Knight move maybe I can't make any
progress until I get the rooks off no no
I want to do something else here I want
to do something else I want to my knight
maybe what needs to get here I think
that might be a good idea I'm gonna try
that okay where's that night going
what's the big idea here get him here I
think here it's gonna be challenged soon
isn't it what about rook here am i not
close to changing the structure in a way
that's maybe beneficial to me like rook
here you can't take my knight because
it's in a pen forty some seconds let's
try this
okey a defends the knight now so I could
get a structural change or maybe a King
and pawn endgame I'm gonna play this
endgame bishop versus knowing yeah let's
do this
pawn takes I believe I could have
something it's offering a draw I don't
want to draw I'm really trying to win
this one
King position and I think I should be
having something bishop here is very
strong get there man get there I've
boxed out the night the King is
restricted get my king in hmm oh man I
need to come back I have to defend c6 my
bishop gonna get hit
you got a runaway let's go here okay
came here fella man alright let's do
this
um okay my king is really going in their
own direction oh man
really I'm have any time wow I'm in so
much trouble isn't he gonna turn out to
be a passed pawn though what am I
missing here what why would you do that
why would you do that
oh why did I go there it's a draw though
still isn't it yeah or is it I wish I
had more time to calculate he's gonna
eat up these guys feel like I should
have something but hmm there's just no
time I wish I had more time mmm should I
go for it I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna
try something and try something let's
see
mmm it's still gonna be a draw
here's barely huh just barely the
Knights boxed out you know who play here
though no what can you do it's a draw I
tried I tried I tried it's not happening
though you get my pun I get yours
call today yeah there we go
I thought Hamels ran out of time trying
to click on that draw button it offered
me another draw right there at the end
mmm I don't know boy I thought I had I'm
close to being in a knot when it was
this position right here
but this Knight maneuver mm-hmm
that was a different story wasn't it yep
yeah that was tough in this pawn advance
that really scared me hmm was there
still some hope I sure did feel like
there would have been something maybe
there was let me let me go into this a
little bit curious here if you didn't
realize let me flip the board was there
way too just like at this point the king
is so fast to eat these guys up I wonder
if I could have done something like this
but then the King's gonna be here as
soon as I do that he's seen him him and
then he's passed thinking like is there
way I could get up here and not even
allowed the knight to sack itself for my
pawn - too difficult for me to calculate
during the game and even now
this isn't something painful is going to
happen